I think every state in America feels a
little bit like a different country have
you been to other states in America that
you're like what the it's so different
i' I've been on the road with Jim a
couple of times and there's places where
I can't even get Easter salad like it's
insane yeah you've been to Cincinnati
yeah we been to Cleveland we've been to
obviously La San Francisco Gilford New
Hampshire bir show oh nice I want to go
to the South sometimes maybe South is
awesome yes have you been Texas yet or
no no not yet oh do great in Texas oh
yeah you think they will love you yeah
this is like Dallas like this is you
know do they all have guns there in
Texas is that cuz in Florida we were
just in Sarasota and I learned that
everyone carries there 80% is it the
same in Texas they carry yes 80% oh I
don't know if it's 80% do you want a gun
yes see this is what B like she's this
is true she's the only person and and I
reloaded in Jim's
mouth